on this July 4th we celebrate those who
want America's independence one of those
brave souls was a woman whom history
refer refers to as molly Pitcher but
that name is folklore tonight we learn
about the real woman behind the legend
and the search to find her my colleague
Bret Baier has her story
Wounded Warrior
prisoner-of-war disabled veteran and an
inspiration to serve Jennifer - is
talking about her hero
Margaret Corbin one of the first women
to fight in the American Revolution
Margaret Corbin's life and actions are
not just a story they are not just
folklore she was a real woman who lived
fought and was recognized by name in
congressional acts and War Department
correspondence up to 1790 Corbin's
heroic story started on November 16th
1776 when she took over her husband's
cannon after he was killed during the
Battle of Fort Washington in Upper
Manhattan from across the Hudson River
General George Washington watched as
some 3,000 Americans battled 9,000
British and Hessian troops it was a
devastating loss for the Americans many
were wounded including Corbin who was
hit by grapeshot in her shoulder and
breast leaving her disabled for the rest
of her life on July 6 1779 Corbin
nicknamed captain Molly was awarded a
lifelong army pension from the
Kahn's making her the first woman
veteran of the United States
Corbin died in 1800 and was buried in an
unmarked graves in 1926 the Daughters of
the American Revolution pinpointed what
the group believed was Corbin's graves a
few miles south of West Point the
disinterred remains were taken to West
Point and buried underneath a monument
depicting Corbin
but in 2016 a shocking discovery was
made when a grave site disturbance led
to an archaeological study of those
remains a forensic exam proved it was
not coordinated but rather an
unidentified man from the 19th century
now a hunt is on to find this American
Hero Margaret Corbin is a veteran of the
United States she deserves to have the
burial that she earned with her military
service in the Battle of Fort Washington
most would agree especially Corbin's
descendants oniton Corbin has spent his
entire life tracing his 31 ancestors who
fought in the American Revolution my
father was the one who told us about
Mark Harmon and would read the story to
us as he liked to do I asked my teacher
how come Molly Corbin's not in this
textbook where she should be because she
was a real hero and she didn't know the
answer
and I hope that that that changes
because we need to give fuller
recognition to what women have done
Corbin's monument was erected at West
Point some 50 years before the first
female cadets for decades she has served
as a model of unflinching bravery and
sacrifice for women in the US military
and for - a mother and a former West
Point instructor Corbin is a source of
inspiration sometimes some mornings were
not that great with two toddler children
and very difficult and worried about
them but thinking also about what I
needed to do the rest of that day in
order to lead and inspire cadets and I
would come out that door right there and
I would see Margaret Corbin's Monument
and I would think if she could do what
she did after watching her husband die
in front of her I could do whatever I
needed to do that day with no problem
Brett Baier Fox News